When you picture a "grizzled police
officer," few TV cops fit the bill
as well as Jason Beghe's "Chicago P.D."
character Squad Commander Hank Voight.
But that grizzled voice isn't an acting choice
– it's a reminder of a near-death experience.
Hank Voight is a classic example of the well
worn "cynical loose cannon" archetype. And
Beghe knows how to look and act tough. But best
of all, he has that unforgettably rough-sounding
voice to convincingly sell his crime-fighting
persona on screen. Only a chain-smoking gargoyle
who drinks broken glass for breakfast could
hope to match the gravitas in Beghe's voice.
"We don't have enough to get a
search warrant for his damn house!"
Beghe's role as Hank Voight began in
Season 1 of "Chicago Fire." Since then,
the character has become iconic, making
guest appearances in several other network
television procedurals, including in "Law
& Order: Special Victims Unit," "Chicago
Med," and "Chicago Justice" as well as
"Chicago P.D." When fans first meet his
character in "Chicago Fire," Voight
seems to be a dirty cop who covers up
criminal activities for self-interest. But as
"Chicago P.D." and future appearances confirm,
there is much more bubbling beneath the surface
of this complicated law enforcement leader.
"You're telling me you won't give me a warrant
based on a tip from a reliable informant."
And as fans know, Beghe's voice is
pitch-perfect for Voight's character. However,
it's not a voice that he's had to tweak over
time to perfect. That's his real-life voice.
What "Chicago P.D." fans might not know is
that his voice wasn't always so pleasantly
rough on the ears. His distinctively gritty
sound is the result of a car accident that
the star had in 1999 – and that near-death
experience forever altered the actor's life.
In an interview with The Daily Beast,
Beghe explained that his naturally deep
voice became exacerbated as a result
of the terrible car accident. He said:
"[I] broke my neck, my back in a couple of
places, all of my ribs, both of my lungs. I
was in a coma for three and a half weeks. When I
would come out of the coma — since I was intubated
from being on life support — I would pull the
tube out and it made it even more f---ed up."
The change in tone is clear when you
look at some of his pre-accident roles,
like his guest turn on Melrose Place.
"It kind of flies in the face
of that 'all men are created
equal' thing I dedicated my life to defend."
The fact that this brush with death would
help Beghe play his most famous role years
down the line is a silver lining to
an otherwise dire situation. However,
his deep voice comes in handy for more
than just playing "bad cop." Within the
same interview, Beghe joked that his
voice also helps him play tough Dad.
"When I say, 'Hey, it's time
to clean up,' they do it."
Beyond the accident giving him the
perfect voice for a morally gray cop,
Beghe acknowledges how the accident had a serious
effect on his life. In an interview with the
Pittsburgh Post-Gazette in 2021, Beghe discussed
how the car accident affected him psychologically.
"Technically, I did die for a short period
of time when I was in the coma. That was
definitely an experience that profoundly informed
my perception of what life is. Twenty years later,
it's not something I think about very
often. But as you bring it up to me,
I do believe that I've probably
permanently changed since then."
Perhaps that is why Beghe appreciates
Voight's direct demeanor, which pushes
his fellow "Chicago P.D." characters to
live authentically and stand by their
point of view. In 2023, Beghe reflected on
Voight's no-nonsense character, stating,
"One thing that Voight insists on and
admires — and it's hard for his team to
do — is he always wants you to be
you. Don't be me. He doesn't want
a team of Voights [...] It can create
some tension but it does create trust."
"The right thing? Are you kidding me?
You want to talk about the right thing?!"